[Music]
motion you have an incredible story uh
casher in the rye this is a real book
that's available right now and you talk
about your actual book and it's right
there guys yeah you talk about your
father uh ver uh hasidic is that correct
am i saying it correctly
just will do all you have to say
so i'm honen uh
your father's acidic what was that like
for you uh describe that for us growing
up that way well my dad was not hasidic
when we started yeah my parents got
divorced and then i went back to new
york six years later to find that my dad
had joined up with a group of hasidic
jews called the satmar hasidim who are
the most weird of all the hasidic jews
let me just say that again so that you
understand of all the fat amish bearded
penguins you see walking around my
father joined up with the group that was
among the weirdest and most outside the
margins of society the group that had
them saying what's with those guys you
know it's like being among the fattest
of all walmart shoppers it's very
difficult
where did he move what part of new york
are we talking about here he moved to a
place called seagate which is in
brooklyn brooklyn okay i'll tell you how
to get there uh if you take the f train
to the last possible stop you get off
walk past coney island pass uh the
people of color pass the projects
through a gate through a time portal to
pre-nazi europe
you will then arrive in seagate where
people are still using horse-drawn buggy
and spitting at redheads because they're
bad luck sorry conan
and that
that was never been spit at well not for
that reason yeah
i would i would do it now but it's
against our religion to do it on
national television
but that's i would then go into this
community and pretend to be a hasidic
jew for six weeks a year i didn't know i
would just be like shucking and jiving
like like me ah
and al jolson yeah
so that's the community that i grew up
in i mean it was it was a very intense
thing and then my bar mitzvah came
around and you know they have like some
people have themes to their bar mitzvahs
like the yankees or indiana jones and a
harrison ford look alike will pop out of
a cake and whip a pinata and then a
waterfall of golden chocolate coins
spills out which by the way i'm very
disturbed by the idea of the golden
chocolate coin is the go-to celebratory
snack for the jewish people like are we
not concerned with our reputation as
shylocks and money grubbers at all
what are people supposed to think when
they see us eating money
[Applause]